PLEASURE TO BE IN THEING TO
COLEMAN, A FLIP OF THE PUCK, INE
LINEUP AFTER SITTI
SNEAKING IN, BACKDOOR, TOFFOLI
WITH KOSKINEN HANGINGGTON THAT ,
WIDE.
KYLINGTON AGAIN, BACK TODOROV.
HARD PASS, DOWN LOW, COLEMAN.
COULE A
TOUGH NIGHT FOR NURSE.
>> Rick: THA
AND THE STICK IN THE WAY, KEITH,
>> Kelly: AND IF
>> Kelly: OH, I WISH.
>> Rick: YOU REMEMBER 190?
[ Laug 2-4-1.
LAST SEVEN.
>> Kelly: ANDANIFIN
WHO BACKS IT ALL THE WAY TOWN
THE ICE.
NOW MIDWAY THROUGH THENSON THERY
HYMAN F F OF ZONE ON THE P.K. FR
CALG
SNEAKY SHOT BY McDAVID WITH
MARKSTROM
WITH DARNELL NURSE.
HEAD UP, FEEDING THAT PASS RIGHT
UP THE MIDDL
SIDE OF CENTRE T T THE ICE RIGHT
NOW AND I DO NOTONTROL, AWAY THY
GO, CARRIEDSAVE OF THIS GAME SOD
RE
TKACHUK.
ANDERSSON.
PASSING, DEFLECTED WIDE NOW BY
GAUDREAU WITHT THROUGH THE LEGS
AND THE FLAMES GETTING THAT PUCK
NOW BACK TO THE POINT AND
TKACHUK HERE, T DOWN.
RUZICKA, THAT PASS, BLOCKED.
AND ZADOROV, REGAINING CONTROL.
THE PUCK
PASS TO HIM IN THEN.
McDAVID NOW ON EDMONTON L GREATR
PLAY. IS AN OPPORTUNITY TO
SURVEY, TO THE LINE ANDHE BLUE
LINE WITH A PASS TOHEIR EYES OP.
>> Kelly: AND THAT IS JERRY, OND
HE GOT A STEP AND MARKSTROM THAT
TIME ABLE EDMONTON, NOW
SHOT BY NURSE, TURNED ASIDE BY
THE ONLY WAY THAT THAT DOES NOT
COUNT IS IF THAT PUCK GOES OFFFF
LOOKING TO SETTLE IT DOWN, A
BOUNCING PUCKKARY POWER PLAY ANE
COVERS UP NOW.E, LOSING THAT
HANDLE AND TIPPED AHEAD NOW. IT.
FOUR OILERS NOW THROUGH CENEN TS
BEHIND HIM AND THAT